bonjour Fabrice merci d'être avec nous
alors c'est un véritable une victoire
mais aussi un soulagement pour l'État
puisque finalement ce projet n'aura pas
à passer devant devant le Parlement le
Conseil d'État a donné son feu vert
directement
oui bah on commence à s'habituer à
passer outre les règles démocratiques en
France ça fait depuis 2015 état
d'urgence est devenu le mode de
fonctionnement normal de l'État français
et puis depuis un an et demi avec le
colis d' on est dans un état d'urgence
plus plus où là le Parlement ne sert
plus à grand-chose donc il y a pas
vraiment de raison des déranger
l'une des missions de cette agence sera
d'éviter les ingérences étrangères
surtout en pleine période électorale on
approche des élections présidentielles
une menace qui est prise au sérieux par
les services de sécurité nationale
pourtant que l'on vous l'action de
l'homme n'aura pas d'impact limitée
pourquoi
l'action virginal écoutez on va attendre
de voir ce qu'ils arrivent à repérer
c'est clair c'est que la menace et réel
que elle est totalement avéré il y a eu
une multitude incident entre des armées
troll de l'Internet Cyrus et l'armée
française en sur le territoire
force est de constater que l'attaque a
été extrêmement efficace que le
sentiment
et on en est aujourd'hui à une
substitution progressive
mettre en place de stratégies pour aller
manger
quelque part
on est aujourd'hui dans un monde qui est
hyper connecté où on voit bien que
l'information circule à une vitesse
fulgurante y a-t-il finalement un moyen
une alternative pour les gouvernements
de contrôler ça
oui l'alternatif c'est délicat les
citoyens de leur apprendre la croisée
des sources de la réponds la vérité des
informations de leur apprendre à prendre
du recul sur la formation et sur les
technologies de l'information le
problème c'est que l'État français comme
tous les États du monde profite aussi de
cette de cette citation avec le manque
de recul et qu'ils ont tendance à ne pas
trop réfléchir sur son ordi donc on est
en France comme partout dans le monde
dans cette situation de transition entre
finalement la vérité
traditionnelle ou aujourd'hui on a perdu
dans les réseaux sociaux une explication
du monde
quelque chose
depuis cotation des données
doit être déclenchée après un
signalement de contenu tu fais les
données pourront être conservés au
maximum 6 mois vous avez parlé de voilà
d'un moyen qui pourrait vite devenir
liberticide comment faire pour éviter
cela
il y a aucun moyen d'éviter cela
nous a promis que
c'était les données de vidéosurveillance
et on a eu à l'occasion de l'affaire
Benalla une déclaration de la préfecture
de Paris qui annoncer que tu es même pas
au courant
après avoir
des données qui avait bien plus d'un an
donc non il y a pas de garantie possible
que
ce soit
tout simplement
juger attentatoire ou aux intérêts d'un
pays
alors déjà il y a un problème sur le
concept de juger Alan attentatoire
sous quelle forme est-ce que on est dans
un jugement de type Démocratique avec un
autre problème
dans une
année
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment donc
tout ça est beaucoup plus conçu c'est
quelque chose que les les étangs
beaucoup de mal à comprendre parce que
pour elle il s'agit de l'entreprise mais
la réalité c'est que Facebook n'est pas
tout à fait
mais
[Musique]
merci beaucoup